Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local Crisis Centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. Nestled in the centre of a clearing hidden amongst tall birch and pine trees was a small light-coloured A-frame tent. Ruth Colley had spotted it as she wandered through the glade with her five-year-old daughter. The secluded campsite overlooked Lake Budam's clear and tranquil waters from a vantage point
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛心的事件。如果您在任何时候觉得需要支持，请联系您当地的危机干预中心。有关机密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用程序上或我们网站上的本期节目简介。在隐蔽于高大桦树和松树之间的林间空地中央，坐落着一顶浅色的小型 A 字形帐篷。露丝·科利（Ruth Colley）在带着她五岁的女儿在林间空地漫步时发现了它。这个幽静的营地从一个有利位置俯瞰着布达姆湖（Lake Budam）清澈平静的水面，
along the eastern peninsula. The tent itself was not an unusual find. Located in southern Finland, Lake Budam was a hive of activity on the morning of Sunday, June 5, 1960. With the ice and snow blanketing the countryside having long since melted away, outdoor enthusiasts had flocked to the lake to swim, sunbathe, and go fishing. Some opted to camp throughout the patch of forest, framing the three-kilometre-long waterfront. When Ruth Colley stumbled across one such campsite, it was far from surprising, yet
位于东部半岛沿岸。这顶帐篷本身并不是什么罕见的发现。1960年6月5日星期日早晨，位于芬兰南部的布达姆湖是一处热闹非凡的活动中心。随着乡间覆盖的冰雪早已融 the 化，户外爱好者们纷纷涌向湖边游泳、晒太阳和钓鱼。有些人选择在勾勒出三公里长水岸线的这片森林中露营。当露丝·科利无意中发现这样一个营地时，这并不让人意外，然而
something drew her closer into the quiet clearing. This centrepiece, the A-frame tent, had collapsed in on itself. There were several people seemingly asleep amid the disarray. It was difficult to distinguish what was what in the tangle of limbs, hair, and belongings, but Ruth could see two teenage girls lying more or less side by side. A boy about the same age lay slightly apart from them. And there was a second adolescent male who was more exposed than his friends. He was lying on his back, directly on top of the tent, with his legs bent.
有什么东西吸引她走进了这片安静的空地。这个核心景观——那顶 A 字形帐篷——已经塌陷了。在一片混乱之中，有几个人看起来正在睡觉。在四肢、头发和随身物品的纠缠中很难分辨出谁是谁，但露丝可以看到两个十几岁的女孩大致并排躺着。一个年纪相仿的男孩与他们略微隔开一点。还有一个第二名青少年男性，比他的朋友们暴露得更多。他仰面躺在帐篷正上方，双腿弯曲。
His face was smeared with blood, and flies buzzed around his head. Bottles of alcohol scattered around the area led Ruth to suspect she was looking at the fallout of a drunken and violent argument between some young campers, who were now sleeping off their hangovers. She moved away and continued along the peninsula with her daughter to meet up with the rest of their family. Soon, Ruth spotted her husband, Marty, and their son in their fishing boat about 200 metres offshore.
他的脸上满是血迹，苍蝇在他的头部周围嗡嗡直叫。散落在这个区域的酒瓶让露丝怀疑，她看到的是一些年轻露营者之间发生暴力酒后争执后的残局，他们现在正在宿醉中沉睡。她走开了，和女儿沿着半岛继续前行，去和家里的其他人会合。不久，露丝看到她的丈夫马蒂（Marty）和他们的儿子正在离岸约200米的渔船上。
She waved them over. Marty Colley rode over to where his wife and daughter were waiting. Ruth informed him about the four teenagers camping nearby, and Marty decided to check on them. He strode up the ridge and was confronted by the same confusing scene that had troubled his wife. Marty recognised the teens. He had seen them arrive the previous day.
她挥手把他们叫了过来。马蒂·科利把船划向妻子和女儿等待的地方。露丝向他通报了附近露营的四个年轻人，马蒂决定去查看一下。他大步走上山脊，迎面看到了那个让他妻子感到不安的同样混乱的场景。马蒂认出了这些青少年。他前一天曾看到他们到达。
At around 5pm, the group of four had wrought up to the south side of the lake on two motorcycles. The boys were driving, and each had a girl clinging to his back. They'd seemed like a happy group, all smiles and laughter. Marty leaned in closer to inspect the mess before him. As he gazed at the tense filthy and collapsed canvas, he realised that large swaths of it had been slashed open with a knife. Nils Gustafson and Sepple Boysman had been best friends since they were 12 years old. With just four months between them, the pair were inseparable and frequently had sleepovers
大约下午5点，这个四人小组成员骑着两辆摩托车轰鸣着来到湖的南侧。男孩们开着车，每人背上都紧紧抓着一个女孩。他们看起来像是一个快乐的群体，满脸笑容和笑声。马蒂凑近去检查眼前的这片混乱。当他凝视着那紧绷、污秽且塌陷的帆布时，他意识到很大一部分被人用刀割开了。尼尔斯·古斯塔夫森（Nils Gustafson）和塞普·博伊斯曼（Seppo Boysman）自12岁起就是最好的朋友。两人年龄只相差四个月，形影不离，经常在
at each other's homes. As they grew older, their lives followed similar paths. They became electricians after graduating school and gained employment at the same electromechanical plant. By May of 1960, Sepple had turned 18 and was dating 15-year-old high school student Anya Mackie, who went by her middle name of Tulikie. Tulikie introduced Sepple and Nils to her own best friend, Myla Björklund. She was also 15 and was known by her middle name, Irmely.
彼此家中留宿过夜。随着年龄增长，他们的人生轨迹也很相似。学校毕业后，他们都成了电工，并在同一家机电厂找到了工作。到1960年5月，塞普已经满18岁，当时正在与15岁的高中生安娅·麦基（Anya Mackie）交往，她以中间名图利基（Tulikie）为人所知。图利基把塞普和尼尔斯介绍给了她自己最好的朋友迈拉·比约克隆德（Myla Björklund）。她也是15岁，以中间名伊尔梅莉（Irmely）为人所知。
Irmely was charmed by Nils, with his slicked back brown hair and rockabilly fashion sense inspired by the king of rock and roll, Elvis Presley. The pair officially became a couple just after Nils' 18th birthday. About two weeks later, the four teenagers decided that an overnight camping trip to Lake Budum would be a great way to celebrate the start of the holidays. Irmely was particularly excited about the upcoming break, as it was the first summer where she wasn't needed to look after her two younger brothers. Despite the girls' excitement, their parents were reluctant to give their blessing for the trip.
伊尔梅莉被尼尔斯迷住了，他那向后梳理的棕色头发以及受摇滚之王埃尔维斯·普雷斯利（Elvis Presley）启发而来的山地摇滚（rockabilly）时尚感深深吸引了她。就在尼尔斯18岁生日后不久，两人正式成为了情侣。大约两周后，这四个青少年决定，去布达姆湖进行一次过夜露营之旅将是庆祝假期开始的好方法。伊尔梅莉对即将到来的假期格外兴奋，因为这是她第一个夏天不需要照顾两个年幼的弟弟。尽管女孩们的兴奋溢于言表，但她们的父母却很不情愿为这次旅行给予祝福。
Although they had always found Sepple and Nils respectful and trustworthy, the idea of their young daughters staying out overnight didn't sit right. Eventually, both Irmely and Tulikie's parents relented and they were permitted to go. The boys fared much easier. Sepple convinced his mother and father that the trip would be safe, as the lake was only a 30-minute drive northwest from their home city of Helsinki. It wasn't as though they would be camping in some remote wilderness. Nils' parents had no problem with him camping and fishing with Sepple for the night,
尽管他们一直觉得塞普和尼尔斯很有礼貌且值得信赖，但想到他们年幼的女儿们在外面过夜还是让他们觉得不太对劲。最终，伊尔梅莉和图利基的父母都妥协了，并允许她们前往。男孩们的进展要顺利得多。塞普说服了他的母亲和父亲，这次旅行将会很安全，因为湖泊距离他们位于赫尔辛基的家乡开车向西北方向只需30分钟。他们又不是要去什么偏远的荒野露营。尼尔斯的父母对于他和塞普一起露营钓鱼过夜没有意见，
although Nils failed to mention that the girls would be with them. And so it was settled. On Saturday, June 4, 1960, Sepple, Nils, Tulikie and Irmely would venture to Lake Budum. The timing was perfect for the young couples, as they would wake up together on the morning of the Christian holiday known as Pentecost. In Finland, there was a saying, if you don't have a sweetheart on Pentecost, you won't have one all summer. Sepple borrowed a canvas tent from work and got his hands on some alcohol, a half-liter bottle of Salmasari liquor, a 370-milliliter bottle of citrus liquor, and a couple of pale lagers.
尽管尼尔斯没有提及女孩们也会和他们一起去。事情就这样决定了。1960年6月4日星期六，塞普、尼尔斯、图利基和伊尔梅莉将前往布达姆湖。对于这对年轻情侣来说，时机再好不过了，因为他们将在被称为圣灵降临节的基督教节日早晨一起醒来。在芬兰有一句俗语：如果在圣灵降临节没有心上人，那么整个夏天你都不会有。塞普从工作单位借了一个帆布帐篷，并弄到了一些酒：半升萨尔马萨里（Salmasari）烈酒、370毫升柑橘味烈酒，以及几瓶淡拉格啤酒。
The boys packed bread, sausages, snacks, and fishing equipment, as well as various knives and a pair of pliers to use as tools. By Saturday afternoon, Nils and Sepple were cruising to Lake Budum on their motorcycles, their girlfriends clinging tightly to their respective backs. At about 5pm, they pulled up to the south side of the lake and found the ideal camping spot at the tip of a small peninsula. It was a short walk east from the lake's main swimming area, but was screened off from the beach by another small peninsula in between. They unloaded their bags in a clearing that overlooked the lake.
男孩们打包了面包、香肠、零食、钓鱼装备，以及用作工具的各种刀具和一把钳子。到周六下午，尼尔斯和塞普骑着摩托车驰骋前往布达姆湖，他们的女朋友紧紧抓着各自的后背。大约下午5点，他们驶抵湖泊南侧，在一个小半岛的顶端找到了理想的营地。从湖泊的主要游泳区向东走一小段路便可到达，但中间隔着另一个小半岛，将这里与海滩隔离开来。他们在俯瞰湖泊的一片空地上卸下了行囊。
Rather than setting up camp right away, they fired up the motorbikes again and headed back about a kilometer down the road to a kiosk they had passed on the way in. There, the boys bought several packets of chewing gum and a few bottles of soft drink as mixes for their liquors. By the time the group arrived back at their campsite, it was about 7.15pm. There were still a few swimmers in the water, but their numbers were dwindling. Nils and Sepple unrolled the tent with the opening facing east, away from the swimming beach. They cut some thick birch sticks from the trees and sharpened them into makeshift tent poles. One of the boys found a decent sized rock down by the shore and used it to hammer the
他们没有马上搭建营地，而是重新发动摩托车，沿着来时的路倒回大约一公里，去了一家他们在路上经过的小卖部。在那里，男孩们买了几包口香糖和几瓶软饮料，作为调配烈酒的混饮。当这群人回到营地时，大约是晚上7点15分。水里还有几个游泳的人，但人数正在减少。尼尔斯和塞普展开了帐篷，开口朝东，背对游泳海滩。他们从树上砍下了一些粗桦树枝，将它们削尖作为临时帐篷杆。其中一个男孩在岸边找到了一块大小合适的石头，并用它把
stakes into the ground. Then they tied off the guidelines and stepped back to admire their handiwork. It was a typical 8-frame tent, which stood at 113cm at its highest point through the middle, not tall enough for any of them to stand inside. At 138cm wide, it barely had room for two, but the four teens would make it work. It was just going to be a very tight fit. Early the next morning, two teenage friends were strolling along the southern shore of Lake Budum. Just before 6am, the boys reached the eastern peninsula when they heard a voice. Drawn to the sound, they climbed up a ridge and into the surrounding woodland to investigate. There, they spotted two motorcycles leaning up against some birch trees. Behind them,
地钉敲进土里。然后他们绑好防风绳，退后一步欣赏他们的手艺。这是一顶典型的 A 字形帐篷，中间最高处为113厘米，高度不足以让任何人站在里面。宽度为138厘米，几乎没有容纳两个人的空间，但这四个青少年将设法将就。这只是一个非常拥挤的空间。第二天一大早，两个少年朋友正沿着布达姆湖的南岸漫步。早上6点前不久，男孩们到达东部半岛时听到一个声音。循着声音，他们爬上一座山脊，进入周围的林地进行调查。在那里，他们看到两辆摩托车靠在几棵桦树上。在它们后面，
in a clearing, was a collapsed tent. The boys were certain that a man was lying on top of it. They couldn't see his face, but they spotted a pair of legs in dark trousers. It looked like he was stirring slightly. Then, some activity a little further away caught their attention. Another man was heading away from the tent into the trees. The boys didn't see his face, but he looked to be an adult wearing a light-colored shirt. They couldn't tell which direction he headed after reaching the trees. Perhaps he'd stopped walking once he was hidden from view. The boys wanted to take a closer look at the motorcycles, but decided they shouldn't risk disturbing the campers and left. 14-year-old Olivier Kivillati was perched on a rocky outcropping
在一片空地上，是一顶塌陷的帐篷。男孩们确信有一个男人正躺在它上面。他们看不清他的脸，但他们发现了一双穿着深色长裤的腿。看起来他正在微微挪动。接着，稍远处的一些动静引起了他们的注意。另一个男人正从帐篷走向树林。男孩们没有看到他的脸，但他看起来像是一个穿着浅色衬衫的成年人。他们无法分辨他在到达树林后朝哪个方向走去。也许他在视线被挡住后就停下了脚步。男孩们想近距离看看那些摩托车，但认为不应该冒险打扰露营者，于是便离开了。14岁的奥利维尔·基维拉蒂（Olivier Kivillati）栖息在一处岩石露头
overlooking Lake Budum, waiting for his fishing buddy. The sun had already risen by the time he'd arrived and the morning was calm and quiet. Then, at about 6am, Olivier's solitude was broken by a man emerging from some trees near the base of the eastern peninsula, about 80 metres away. He looked to be in his 20s, was of average height, and had brown hair combed backwards. He was wearing a light top and dark pants. The man moved quickly and purposefully down to the peninsula's base and continued south before disappearing out of Olivier's sight. It was several hours later when Ruth Collie discovered the collapsed tent and pointed it out to her husband. By 10am, more people had noticed the tent, including a group of teenagers who had
俯瞰着布达姆湖，等待着他的钓鱼搭档。他到达时太阳已经升起，早晨平静而安静。然后，大约早上6点，奥利维尔的孤独被一个从东部半岛基部附近的树林里钻出来的男人打破了，距离大约80米。他看起来20多岁，中等身材，棕色头发向后梳理。他穿着一件浅色上衣和深色裤子。那个男人迅速而有目的地走到半岛的基部，向南走去，然后消失在奥利维尔的视线之外。几个小时后，露丝·科利发现了塌陷的帐篷并将其指给她的丈夫看。到上午10点，更多人注意到了这顶帐篷，其中包括一群曾经
been swimming in the lake. They too thought it looked as though the young campers had been in a fight and carried on with their morning. Then, at 11.15am, a passerby realised something far more sinister had taken place and rushed to a nearby construction site. Using the phone in its office to call the police, he informed them that there had been a slaughter at Lake Budum. Upon observing the campsite for themselves, local officers immediately contacted the central criminal police. Special investigators arrived and examined the bodies bundled close together. Sepo Boiseman was lying under the folds at the edge of the tent. His legs, dressed in blue jeans that were unbuttoned at the fly, were outstretched. He also wore a blue
在湖里游泳的青少年。他们也觉得年轻的露营者像是打过架一样，于是继续过他们的早晨。接着，在上午11点15分，一名路人意识到发生了更为险恶的事情，于是冲到附近的一个建筑工地。他利用办公室里的电话报警，通知他们布达姆湖发生了一场屠杀。在亲眼观察了营地后，当地警官立即联系了中央刑警。特别调查人员赶到并检查了紧紧捆绑在一起的尸体。塞普·博伊斯曼（Seppo Boiseman）正躺在帐篷边缘的褶皱下。他的双腿伸直着，穿着蓝色牛仔裤，裤门拉链没有扣上。他还穿着一件蓝色
collared shirt and his hands rested on his chest, almost as if he was sleeping. But Sepo was not asleep. He had been hit with a blunt object multiple times in the head and jaw, producing four fractures to the left side of his skull. Curious onlookers watched as a police officer lifted one of the tent folds that covered Sepo's head, revealing that he had also been stabbed through the tent's canvas. There were wounds in his neck and trachea. The fatal strike was another stab wound that had punctured Sepo's chest cavity. He would not have been able to move before he bled out into his lungs. His girlfriend, Tuliki Mackie, was curled up, face down, and partially covered with a blanket.
有领衬衫，双手放在胸前，几乎就像是在睡觉。但塞普并没有在睡觉。他的头部和下巴多次遭到钝器击打，导致头骨左侧出现四处骨折。好奇的旁观者看着一名警察掀起盖住塞普头部的其中一个帐篷褶皱，暴露出他也曾被刺穿帐篷帆布。他的脖子和气管上有伤口。致命的一击是另一处刺穿塞普胸腔的刺伤。在他血液流入肺部之前，他根本无法动弹。他的女朋友图利基·麦基（Tuliki Mackie）蜷缩着，面朝下，身上部分盖着一条毯子。
Her blue jeans were fastened, but her yellow blouse had ridden up her torso, exposing her mid-riff. She too had suffered severe blunt force trauma to her head, which caused multiple fractures to her skull. Irmily Björklund was near the tent's doorway, her left leg paralleled to Tuliki's back, and her right leg bent around Tuliki's head. Irmily's light green jeans were down below her knees, with the right pant leg pulled off entirely, exposing her lower half. Her beige blouse and light blue sweater had also been pulled up to her shoulders, exposing her torso and bra. At least three powerful strikes with a blunt heavy object had shattered Irmily's skull across her forehead and produced further fractures along her jaw and the side of her face.
她的蓝色牛仔裤系着，但黄色衬衫向上滑到了躯干，露出了腹部。她也遭受了严重的头部钝力创伤，导致头骨多处骨折。伊尔梅莉·比约克隆德（Irmely Björklund）在帐篷门口附近，她的左腿与图利基的背部平行，右腿环绕着图利基的头部弯曲。伊尔梅莉浅绿色的牛仔裤退到了膝盖以下，右裤腿完全被脱掉，露出了下半身。她的米色衬衫和浅蓝色毛衣也被拉到了肩膀处，露出了躯干和胸罩。用重型钝器进行的至少三次猛烈击打击碎了伊尔梅莉的前额头骨，并在她的下巴和脸侧产生了更多的骨折。
These blows were enough to cause severe swelling and bleeding of the brain, resulting in almost immediate death. But the killer had also stabbed Irmily 15 times in her neck and shoulders. She had clearly borne the brunt of the attack. Nils Gustafson was lying on top of the tent, dressed in a grey sweater, dark jeans, and socks. The entire left side of his face was swollen and bruised, including his eye, which was sealed shut. Nils had suffered a fracture to the left side of his lower jaw and another to the temporal bone, otherwise known as the ear canal. The left side of his upper jaw and his cheekbone were also fractured. Nils had been slashed multiple times with a knife. He had a gash on the back of his
这些打击足以导致严重的大脑肿胀和出血，几乎当场死亡。但凶手还对伊尔梅莉的颈部和肩膀进行了15次刺伤。她显然承受了袭击的最主要部分。尼尔斯·古斯塔夫森躺在帐篷顶部，穿着一件灰色毛衣、深色牛仔裤和袜子。他脸部的整个左侧都肿胀且有瘀伤，包括他的眼睛，已经肿得闭合。尼尔斯遭受了左下颌骨折和另一处颞骨骨折，也就是通常所说的耳道骨折。他上颌的左侧和颧骨也骨折了。尼尔斯被刀多次割伤。他的后背上有个裂口
left forearm and another along his left cheek. This second wound was so deep it had cut through the entire depth of skin and muscle, exposing his teeth. Police determined that the killer had intentionally cut the tent's guidelines before the attack. As the tent collapsed onto the sleeping teens, the exact location of each of their heads would have become obvious. The four victims were effectively trapped, confused, and disoriented, with no means of escape. The killer would not have known the order in which they were sleeping, so he likely unleashed the violent blitz attack indiscriminately. Items recovered at the crime scene correlated with what the teens had packed for their weekend getaway. Bags, clothing, cigarette boxes, makeup, bread, and a red leather song book
左前臂和沿左脸颊的另一个。这第二个伤口非常深，以至于切断了整个皮肤和肌肉的深度，露出了他的牙齿。警方确定，凶手在袭击前故意割断了帐篷的防风绳。随着帐篷倒塌在睡觉的青少年身上，他们每个人头部的确切位置将变得显而易见。这四个受害者实际上被困住、感到困惑和迷失方向，没有逃生手段。凶手不会知道他们睡觉的顺序，所以他很可能是无差别地发动了暴力闪击。在犯罪现场找回的物品与青少年为周末度假打包的东西相符。包、衣服、烟盒、化妆品、面包以及一本属于图利基的红色皮革歌本
that belonged to Tuliki were catalogued. Two table knives and two pocket knives were found, but none were the bladed weapon wielded by the killer. The pale lager bottles were found, one empty, one full, along with multiple bottles of soda. Some of the soda bottles were empty, but one still contained a mix of soft drink and the citrus liquor. A foreign fingerprint, not belonging to any of the teens, was found on one bottle. The bottle of saumisari liquor was never located. Other, more crucial items were also missing. Notably, each of the teenagers' wallets and IDs, another knife they had packed, sepals leather jacket, and the keys to the motorcycles. The girls hadn't brought any watches, but the boys had, and they were missing too.
被编入目录。找到了两把餐刀和两把折叠刀，但没有一把是凶手挥舞的刀刃武器。找到了淡拉格啤酒瓶，一个空的，一个满的，还有多瓶汽水。有些汽水瓶是空的，但其中一个仍然装有软饮料和柑橘烈酒的混合物。在一个瓶子上发现了一枚不属于任何青少年的外国指纹。那瓶绍米萨里（Saumisari）烈酒再也没有被找到。其他更关键的物品也失踪了。值得注意的是，每个青少年的钱包和身份证、他们打包的另一把刀、塞普的皮夹克以及摩托车钥匙。女孩们没有带任何手表，但男孩们带了，也失踪了。
Over the next day or two, community volunteers joined police and military personnel in an extensive search of the entire Lake Buldum area. Metal detectors were used and sniffer dogs were deployed, while divers searched the depths of the lake. Items as small as a piece of iron wire were collected. The weapons used in the attack were not located. About 500 meters from the crime scene, just off the road that led to the campsite, a pair of worn brown leather slip-on loafers were found hidden under a rock. They were covered in flecks of blood and were identified as belonging to victim Nils Gustafson. Sepal boys' shoes were also unearthed nearby, discarded more carelessly in the scrub on the other side of the road. An appeal was made to identify the men seen
在接下来的一两天里，社区志愿者与警察和军方人员一起对整个布尔杜姆湖（Buldum Lake）地区进行了广泛搜寻。动用了金属探测器和搜救犬，潜水员则搜寻了湖泊深处。甚至连一块铁丝这样小的物品也被收集起来。袭击中使用的武器没有找到。距离犯罪现场约500米处，就在通往营地的道路旁，一双穿旧的棕色皮革一套式乐福鞋被发现藏在一块石头下。它们上面沾满了血迹，被确认属于受害者尼尔斯·古斯塔夫森。塞普·博伊斯曼的鞋子也在附近被发掘出来，被更随意地丢弃在路另一侧的灌木丛中。警方发出呼吁，要求辨认那些在发现尸体的早晨被看到
walking away from the campsite the morning the bodies were discovered. While this particular individual wasn't identified, sightings of other suspicious persons were called in. Given the brutality and shocking nature of the murders, the provincial government ordered police teams to apprehend all suspects immediately. Dozens of people were brought into police stations across the county for interrogations. One man was arrested based on the suspicions of a bishop. A soldier was also detained after his parents tipped off the police. Both were eventually released. In one more promising lead, a man was arrested when a bloody knife was found in Buldum Village. After tests proved that the blood didn't match any of the victim's blood types, he was
从营地走开的男子。虽然这个特定的人没有被认出来，但接到了关于其他可疑人员的目击报告。鉴于谋杀案的残酷性和令人震惊的性质，省政府下令警方立即抓捕所有嫌疑人。数十人被带到该县各地的警察局接受讯问。一名男子根据主教的怀疑而被捕。一名士兵在父母向警方举报后也被拘留。两人最终都获释了。在一个更有希望的线索中，当在布尔杜姆村发现一把带血的刀时，一名男子被捕。经过测试证明血迹与任何受害者的血型都不匹配后，他被
let go. A bearded, dirty man spotted hiding out in the Buldum forest area was found to be a fugitive named Paoli Luoma. Luoma had received a mandatory labor order likely for vagrancy which was been a crime in Finland but had deserted his sentence. A large-scale manhunt began. The police managed to locate Luoma but he was so drunk that they had to keep him in a holding cell overnight to sober up before they could interrogate him. When Luoma was interviewed the next morning, he was able to name nearly a dozen witnesses who confirmed he had been in a hut outside of Helsinki at the time of the murders. Although the police investigation seemed to be stalling, locals were working on theories of their own. 51-year-old Carl Gilstrom ran the kiosk near the southern part of the lake where
释放了。一名留着胡子、衣衫褴褛的男子被发现在布尔杜姆森林地区躲藏，经查是一名名叫保利·洛马（Paoli Luoma）的逃犯。洛马因流浪（这在芬兰曾是一种犯罪）而收到了一项强制劳役令，但他逃避了刑罚。一场大规模搜捕开始了。警方设法找到了洛马，但他醉得不省人事，以至于他们不得不把他关在拘留室过夜，等他酒醒后才能对其实施讯问。次日早晨对洛马进行盘问时，他说出了近十名证人的名字，他们证实谋杀案发生时他一直在赫尔辛基郊外的一座小屋里。尽管警方调查似乎陷入停滞，但当地人正在研究他们自己的理论。51岁的卡尔·吉尔斯特罗姆（Carl Gilstrom）经营着湖泊南侧附近的小卖部，
visitors often stopped for refreshments and supplies. He also lived in a house a short distance up the road. Gilstrom was of average height and had dark hair that he wore slicked back across his head but the most notable thing about him was his temper. Although he could be friendly and polite especially when authority figures were around, sometimes his mood would flick like a switch. Suddenly he'd turn aggressive and cruel. Locals said that he hid razor blades in the apples that grew from his tree to deter children from picking the fruit. A heavy drinker with a known hatred of the campers who stayed at the lake, Gilstrom was also prone to attacking others. A man who owned land near the lake once caught Gilstrom hunting illegally and asked him to leave.
游客们经常在那里停留购买茶点和补给品。他也住在路上不远的一所房子里。吉尔斯特罗姆中等身材，留着向后梳理过头顶的深色头发，但他最引人注目的是他的脾气。虽然他可能很友好和礼貌，特别是在权威人物在场时，但有时他的情绪会像开关一样切换。突然间他就会变得具有攻击性和残忍。当地人说他在树上结出的苹果里藏剃须刀片，以阻止孩子们采摘果子。吉尔斯特罗姆是一个酗酒者，众所周知他痛恨在湖边逗留的露营者，他也倾向于攻击他人。一个拥有湖泊附近土地的男人曾抓获吉尔斯特罗姆非法狩猎并要求他离开。
Gilstrom raised his shotgun, took aim, then fired at the man. He wasn't seriously hurt but he had to have the shot pellets removed at a hospital. The road leading to his home seemed to be a particular fixation for Gilstrom. One time a truck driver had been heading along the road only to hear a loud crack followed by the shattering of glass. Sharp shards lodged in the driver's face and he realized that someone had shot at him, breaking one of the truck's windows. When Carl Gilstrom was found to be responsible, he claimed he'd only fired at the vehicle to discourage drivers from hooning down the road too fast. Sometimes Gilstrom lined the road with makeshift spike strips consisting of wooden planks
吉尔斯特罗姆举起猎枪，瞄准，然后向那个人开枪。他伤得不重，但不得不在医院取出散弹铅丸。通往他家的路似乎是吉尔斯特罗姆的一个特殊执念。有一次，一名卡车司机正沿着这条路行驶，突然听到一声巨响，接着是玻璃破碎的声音。锋利的碎片扎进司机的脸，他意识到有人向他开枪，打碎了卡车的一扇窗户。当发现卡尔·吉尔斯特罗姆是罪魁祸首时，他声称自己开枪只是为了阻止司机在路上飙车太快。有时吉尔斯特罗姆会在路上铺设由木板组成的临时钉带
with nails jutting out. Gilstrom kept the length of iron pipe in his car and was known to carry a curved and hunting knife on his belt. He was also renowned for something else. He had a history of cutting the guidelines of campers' tents. When Nils Gustafsson, Seppo Boysman, Tulliki Mackie and Irmely Björklund arrived at Lake Budum on June 4, they headed to Gilstrom's kiosk shortly after choosing a campsite. Gilstrom's wife was working by herself behind the counter that day and served the 14s as they purchased soft drinks and chewing gum. They hung around the kiosk for a little while longer, chatting, laughing and enjoying ice cream in the sun. Afterwards, they took off on their motorbikes back down the road towards their campsite,
上面突出钉子。吉尔斯特罗姆在车里放了一段铁管，并且众所周知他在腰带上系着一把弯曲的猎刀。他也因另一件事而闻名。他有割破露营者帐篷防风绳的历史。当尼尔斯·古斯塔夫森、塞普·博伊斯曼、图利基·麦基和伊尔梅莉·比约克隆德于6月4日抵达布达姆湖时，他们在选择营地后不久便前往吉尔斯特罗姆的小卖部。吉尔斯特罗姆的妻子那天独自在柜台后工作，在14岁少年们购买软饮料和口香糖时为他们服务。他们在小卖部多逗留了一会儿，聊天、大笑并在阳光下享用冰淇淋。之后，他们骑着摩托车顺原路返回他们的营地，
passing Gilstrom's home along the way. Gilstrom's wife closed the kiosk at around 9 that night and later told her husband about the 14-ages camping nearby. As investigators examined the grisly crime scene the next morning, one onlooker rushed to the kiosk to inform Gilstrom of the terrible crime. To his surprise, Gilstrom took the information in his stride. In fact, he seemed utterly nonchalant. Not long after the murders, locals learned that Gilstrom had filled in a well located on his property. Aware of his violent temper and dislike of campers, some speculated that Gilstrom was the killer and had disposed of the murder weapons and or the teenagers missing belongings down the well. Their suspicions were strengthened by the
沿途经过吉尔斯特罗姆的家。吉尔斯特罗姆的妻子在当晚9点左右关闭了小卖部，后来把附近露营的14岁少年们告诉了她的丈夫。当调查人员第二天早晨检查可怕的犯罪现场时，一名旁观者冲到小卖部将这起可怕的罪行告知吉尔斯特罗姆。令他惊讶的是，吉尔斯特罗姆泰然处之。事实上，他显得非常漠不关心。谋杀案发生后不久，当地人得知吉尔斯特罗姆填平了其房产内的一口井。由于知道他暴躁的脾气和对露营者的厌恶，一些人推测吉尔斯特罗姆是凶手，并将凶器和或青少年失踪的财物丢进了井里。他们的怀疑因
discovery of Nils and Seppo's shoes along the road that led to Gilstrom's house. Investigators eventually interviewed Gilstrom and his wife. Both said that he was at home asleep on the evening in question. Gilstrom's wife explained that she and the children slept in the bedroom while Gilstrom slept in the kitchen but the door between the two rooms was kept open and her husband never left the house. Police searched the Gilstrom premises, though nothing of significance was uncovered. Yet many locals felt that the police search was far from exhaustive. They hadn't even examined the filled-in well. At 10.45 pm, the day after the murders, an ambulance arrived at Helsinki Surgical Hospital
在通往吉尔斯特罗姆家的路上发现了尼尔斯和塞普的鞋子而得到了加强。调查人员最终对吉尔斯特罗姆和他的妻子进行了盘问。两人都说他在事发当晚在家睡觉。吉尔斯特罗姆的妻子解释说，她和孩子们睡在卧室里，而吉尔斯特罗姆睡在厨房里，但两个房间之间的门一直开着，她的丈夫从未离开过房子。警方搜查了吉尔斯特罗姆的住所，不过没有发现任何重要物品。然而许多当地人认为警方的搜查远谈不上彻底。他们甚至没有检查那口被填平的井。谋杀案发生后的第二天晚上10点45分，一辆救护车抵达赫尔辛基外科医院
with an unconscious adult inside. The patient, a German-born man by the name of Hans Asmann, was wearing dirty overalls covered in red stains. The same stains could be seen all over his hands. According to his wife who had accompanied him, Asmann had collapsed as a result of severe stomach pains. When the doctor poked him during a responsiveness test, Asmann giggled. Apparently, he had been faking his unconsciousness. After Asmann's ruse was discovered, he exhibited no remorse or shame. Instead, he began threatening hospital staff and demanding that he be treated right away. A medical intern was struck by Asmann's strange behavior and kept a close eye on him during
里面躺着一个昏迷的成年人。病人是一名出生于德国名叫汉斯·阿斯曼（Hans Asmann）的男子，穿着沾满红色污渍的脏工作服。同样的污渍在他手上到处可见。据陪同他的妻子称，阿斯曼因剧烈胃痛而晕倒。当医生在反应测试中戳他时，阿斯曼咯咯笑了。显然，他是假装昏迷的。在阿斯曼的把戏被识破后，他没有表现出丝毫的悔意或羞耻。相反，他开始威胁医院工作人员，并要求立即得到治疗。一名医学实习生对阿斯曼的奇怪行为感到震惊，并在他
his stay. At one stage, Asmann was visited by a woman who was not his wife. The pair spoke at length in hushed tones. Asmann also spent hours vigorously washing his hands with paint thinner to remove the red stains. According to Asmann's own claims, he had been a Nazi prison guard at Auschwitz during World War II, before being captured in 1943 by the Russians. After two years in a prisoner of war camp, he supposedly switched sides to join the Soviet Union's security agency, the KGB. Asmann remained in hospital for several days, but that wasn't the last the staff saw of him. After he was discharged, he returned numerous times for further treatment. On one occasion, he showed a doctor a German magazine
住院期间密切关注他。在某个阶段，一个不是他妻子的女人来探望阿斯曼。两人用低沉的声音详谈了很久。阿斯曼还花了几小时用油漆稀释剂大力清洗双手以去除红色污渍。据阿斯曼自己声称，他在第二次世界大战期间曾是奥斯威辛集中营的纳粹狱警，直到1943年被俄国人俘虏。在战俘营呆了两年后，他据称倒戈加入了苏联安全机构克格勃（KGB）。阿斯曼在医院住了几天，但这并不是工作人员最后一次见到他。出院后，他多次返回接受进一步治疗。有一次，他向一名医生展示了一起未破谋杀案的德国杂志
article about an unsolved murder. Another time, he joked to one of the surgeons that he too was skilled with a knife, but unlike the surgeon's patients, those on the other end of Asmann's knife never survived. By July, the doctors at the hospital had grown so suspicious of Hans Asmann that they reported him to the police. The medical intern that initially treated Asmann had been so convinced that the man was somehow connected to the Lake Budum murders that he'd bagged his stained overalls so that police could analyze them. Yet, the authorities didn't seem to share their concerns. There was one other thing that further convinced the hospital staff they were right about Hans Asmann. A month after the crimes, a composite sketch of the Lake Budum
文章。另一次，他向其中一位外科医生开玩笑说他也精通刀具，但与外科医生的病人们不同，那些在阿斯曼刀下的人从没有一个能活下来。到7月份，医院的医生对汉斯·阿斯曼产生了极大的怀疑，以至于他们向警方报案了。最初治疗阿斯曼的医学实习生深信此人与布达姆湖谋杀案有某种联系，以至于他将沾有血渍的工作服装进袋子里以便警方分析。然而，当局似乎并不认同他们的担忧。还有一件事进一步让医院工作人员确信他们对汉斯·阿斯曼的看法是正确的。犯罪发生一个月后，布达姆湖
murders suspect was released. It depicted a man with large eyes, a straight nose, and thick lips. He had long pale hair combed backward. His face was round, but he had a strong jaw and slightly protruding red cheeks that were dotted with pimples. The man's forehead was high and was also pimply with uneven horizontal wrinkles. To hospital staff, the sketch looked remarkably like Hans Asmann. When the sketch was made public, about 50 tips were received as a result. While none yielded anything promising, the sketch was still considered one of the most important leads investigators had. It was based on a description provided by a crucial eyewitness. None other than Nils Gustafsson.
谋杀案嫌疑人的拼图画像被公开发布。它描绘了一个大眼睛、直鼻子和厚嘴唇的男人。他有着向后梳理的浅色长发。他的脸是圆的，但他有着坚毅的下巴和微微突出的红脸颊，上面长满了粉刺。这个男人的前额很高，同样长满粉刺，带有不规则的水平皱纹。对于医院工作人员来说，这张画像看起来与汉斯·阿斯曼惊人地相似。当画像被公之于众时，因此收到了大约50条线索。虽然没有一条产生什么有希望的结果，但这张画像仍被认为是调查人员拥有的最重要线索之一。它是基于一个关键目击者提供的描述。不是别人，正是尼尔斯·古斯塔夫森。
On Thursday, June 9, 1960, four days after the Lake Budum murders, Nils Gustafsson woke with a pounding headache. Strange faint noises accompanied each thump to his brain, leading the 18-year-old to wonder where he was. He tried to look and see, but struggled to bring his surroundings into focus. The problem was his left eye. It was almost swollen shut. Eventually, he managed to force his eyes open. The room took shape, and Nils realized that he was lying in a hospital bed. He saw his mother by his side, and an unfamiliar man who looked to be a doctor. Nils tried to speak, but found it difficult to move his mouth. He strained his eyes downward and saw bandages and a brace of some kind wrapped around his jaw. With great effort, he carefully opened his mouth
1960年6月9日星期四，即布达姆湖谋杀案发生四天后，尼尔斯·古斯塔夫森在一阵剧烈的头痛中醒来。伴随着大脑每一次跳动的是奇怪而微弱的噪音，这让这个18岁的年轻人想知道自己身在何处。他试图睁眼看看，但很难让周围的环境聚焦。问题出在他的左眼上。它几乎肿得闭合了。最终，他设法强行睁开了眼睛。房间有了形状，尼尔斯意识到自己正躺在医院的病床上。他看到母亲在身边，还有一个看起来像医生的陌生男人。尼尔斯试图说话，但发现很难活动嘴巴。他向下吃力地看着，看到绷带和某种支撑物缠绕在下巴周围。他费了很大力气，小心翼翼地张开嘴
and asked his mother if he had been in a motorcycle accident. She hesitated to answer. Nils racked his brain, trying to remember what had happened. He recalled being at Lake Budum with his friends Seppo and Tuliki and his girlfriend Irmily. They all went to sleep in their shared tent sometime after sunset. Before dawn, Seppo headed off alone to go fishing, only to return a short while later without a catch. He resettled in the tent, and all four of them went back asleep. Try as he might. Nils could not remember anything that happened thereafter. When police arrived at the Lake Budum crime scene, they found Nils Gustafson lying on top of the tent, slightly apart from his companions. Unlike the others, Nils was clearly alive,
问母亲自己是不是遭遇了摩托车事故。她犹豫着没有回答。尼尔斯绞尽脑汁，试图回忆发生了什么事。他回想起自己和朋友塞普、图利基以及女友伊尔梅莉在布达姆湖。日落后不久的某个时候，他们都在共用的帐篷里睡着了。黎明前，塞普独自一人去钓鱼，不久后便空手而归。他在帐篷里重新安顿下来，他们四个人又都睡着了。任凭他怎么想。尼尔斯都记不起此后发生的任何事情。当警察到达布达姆湖犯罪现场时，他们发现尼尔斯·古斯塔夫森躺在帐篷顶部，与同伴略微隔开。和其他人不同，尼尔斯显然还活着，
though barely conscious. He'd sustained a number of head injuries, but none were life-threatening. The left side of his face was swollen and beaten. He had been badly cut along his left cheek, and there was a two-inch cut on the back of his left forearm. A police officer peppered Nils with questions as he was rushed to hospital, but only received a series of unintelligible noises in response. The questions continued as physicians worked to stitch up Nils's wounds. How was he able to survive the attack? Had he somehow managed to squeeze out of one of the gaping slashes in the tent? Perhaps he tried to escape or fight back. It was also possible that the two boys who had stumbled
尽管意识微弱。他受了多处头部伤，但没有一处危及生命。他的脸部左侧肿胀并遭到殴打。他的左脸颊被严重割伤，左前臂背面有一道两英寸长的伤口。当尼尔斯被紧急送往医院时，一名警察向他连珠炮般地发问，但只得到了断断续续的一系列难以理解的噪音作为回应。当医师们忙着缝合尼尔斯的伤口时，盘问仍在继续。他是如何在袭击中幸存下来的？他是否设法从帐篷的一个巨大裂口中挤出来？也许他试图逃跑或进行反抗。也有可能那两个早晨很早偶然来到
across the crime scene early that morning had disturbed the attacker, maybe just before Nils was about to receive a fatal blow. Police were hopeful that the sole survivor of the brutal attack could provide them with some answers, but Nils only responded with the occasional faint moan. Nils was monitored in the Traumatology Ward for two days before being transferred to the hospital's neurosurgical wing. It wasn't until June 9, four days after the attack, that he regained full consciousness. One of his first requests was to see his best friend, Seppo. Despite some slight swelling that remained on the left side of his face, the doctors determined that Nils was well enough to be discharged on June 23. The police didn't waste
犯罪现场的少年打扰了袭击者，也许就在尼尔斯即将遭受致命一击之前。警方抱有希望，认为这起残酷袭击的唯一幸存者能为他们提供一些答案，但尼尔斯只偶尔发出微弱的呻吟声作为回应。尼尔斯在创伤外科病房接受了为期两天的监护，然后被转到医院的神经外科病房。直到6月9日袭击发生四天后，他才完全恢复意识。他的第一个要求之一就是见他最好的朋友塞普。尽管他脸部左侧仍有一些残留的肿胀，但医生确定尼尔斯身体状况良好，可以在6月23日出院。警方没有浪费
any time. At noon that day, they ushered Nils out a back exit to avoid the crowds of reporters lingering outside the hospital. He was then driven to the police station and once settled, began his story. After he and Seppo set up the tent between 7.30 and 8 on the evening of Saturday, June 4, the girls went swimming in the lake. The boys remained at the campsite, sharing a lager and fashion fishing rods out of birch branches. They also mixed some liquor with the soda, but didn't finish it because it didn't taste very nice. When the girls returned from their swim, they declined to have a drink. After the sunset at about 9.30 pm, Nils and Irmily kissed and cuddled for a little while. About an hour later, they decided to go to sleep. Somehow, the group of
任何时间。当天中午，他们引导尼尔斯从后门离开，以避开滞留在医院外面的大批记者。随后他被驱车送往警察局，一旦安顿下来，就开始讲述他的故事。他和塞普在6月4日星期六晚上7点30分到8点之间搭好帐篷后，女孩们去湖里游泳。男孩们留在营地，共享一箱拉格啤酒，并用桦树枝制作钓鱼竿。他们还把一些烈酒和苏打水混合在一起，但没有喝完，因为味道不太好。当女孩们游完泳回来时，她们拒绝喝酒。在大约晚上9点30分日落后，尼尔斯和伊尔梅莉亲吻并拥抱了一会儿。大约一个小时后，他们决定去睡觉。不知怎么的，这组
four managed to squeeze into the tent's small confines. Tuliki took position on the far right of the tent, facing inwards with her back to the wall. Seppo was next in line, facing Tuliki. Irmily lay on the tent's left side, also with her back to the wall. Nils entered last and zipped up the tent door, then lay down on his right side, facing Irmily. He used his leather jacket as a makeshift pillow. Hours later, Nils woke to the sound of Seppo rustling in the tent for his fishing tackle. The sun hadn't yet risen, and Nils estimated it was just before 3 am. He felt like going for a swim, so he joined Seppo while the girls continued to sleep. Once they were down at the lake, Seppo perched himself on a rock while Nils tested the water. It was too cold, so he left
四人设法挤进了帐篷狭小的空间里。图利基占据了帐篷的最右侧，面向内侧，背靠着墙壁。塞普排在旁边，面对着图利基。伊尔梅莉躺在帐篷的左侧，同样背靠着墙壁。尼尔斯最后进去，拉上帐篷门，然后右侧身躺下，面对着伊尔梅莉。他用自己的皮夹克当做临时枕头。几个小时后，尼尔斯被帐篷里塞普寻找钓鱼用具的沙沙声吵醒。太阳还没有升起，尼尔斯估计刚过凌晨3点。他想去游泳，于是加入了塞普，而女孩们继续睡觉。一旦他们来到湖边，塞普就坐在一块石头上，而尼尔斯则试了试水温。水太冷了，于是他离开
Seppo fishing and wandered back to the tent. The girls were still inside, but were now awake. A little while later, Seppo returned as well, having had no luck fishing. All four then went back to sleep. So far, Nils' story made sense. Tuliki's red songbook that had been found at the crime scene had contained a diary-style entry that corroborated his version of events. The entry referred to the excursion to Lake Budum and contained three brief lines. The first read Seppo and Nils were drunk, the second that they were up at 2 am, and the third that Seppo was in the woods. The police urged Nils to continue, but Nils said the next thing he remembered was waking up in the hospital. Investigators were dismayed to hear that he had no recollection of the attack.
钓鱼的塞普，溜达着回到了帐篷。女孩们还在里面，但现在已经醒了。过了一会儿，塞普也回来了，因为钓鱼毫无收获。四个人于是又都睡着了。到目前为止，尼尔斯的故事说得通。在犯罪现场发现的图利基的红色歌本里包含一篇日记风格的条目，证实了他的版本。该条目提到了去布达姆湖的远足，并包含三行简短的文字。第一行写着塞普和尼尔斯喝醉了，第二行写着他们凌晨2点起床，第三行写着塞普在树林里。警察敦促尼尔斯继续说下去，但尼尔斯说他接下来记得的事就是醒来时已经在医院了。调查人员听到他完全不记得袭击经过时感到非常沮丧。
They were certain he held the key to solving the case. Despite continued prodding, Nils was insistent. He remembered nothing else. Investigators escorted Nils back to Lake Budum in the hopes that visiting the crime scene would prompt a repressed memory to resurface. The visit didn't seem to provoke anything new in Nils' mind. There was, however, one other option that could be explored. Dr. Asa Stenbeck, a professor of psychiatry who lectured at the University of Helsinki, believed he could access Nils' repressed memories through hypnosis. After having previously attended a short course on psychotherapy and having had some success with
他们确信他掌握着破案的关键。尽管一再催促，尼尔斯还是坚持不懈。他什么也记不得了。调查人员护送尼尔斯回到布达姆湖，希望参观犯罪现场能促使被压抑的记忆重新浮现。这次访问似乎没有在尼尔斯的脑海中激起任何新的东西。不过，还有一个可以探讨的选择。赫尔辛基大学精神病学教授阿萨·斯坦贝克（Asa Stenbeck）博士认为，他可以通过催眠进入尼尔斯被压抑的记忆。此前曾参加过心理治疗短期课程并在与其他患者的交往中取得了一些成功之后，
other patients, Dr. Stenbeck felt he was capable enough for the task. In the month after the murders, Dr. Stenbeck conducted three hypnotherapy sessions with Nils, each lasting around 30 minutes. Nils shared no new information in the first two. During the third, Dr. Stenbeck asked the hypnotized Nils if he'd heard any screams that night. Nils replied that he'd faintly heard the girls screaming, crying out that someone had attacked them. Dr. Stenbeck asked Nils what he then saw. Nils said that the roof of the tent was on top of them. A man started hitting them with a sharp weapon, maybe a knife, and also a hard weapon, like an iron pipe. Dr. Stenbeck asked if Nils had seen the man before.
斯坦贝克博士觉得他有足够的能力来完成这项任务。在谋杀案发生后的一个月里，斯坦贝克博士对尼尔斯进行了三次催眠治疗，每次持续约30分钟。尼尔斯在前两次中没有透露任何新信息。在第三次治疗期间，斯坦贝克博士问处于催眠状态的尼尔斯，那天晚上他是否听到任何尖叫声。尼尔斯回答说，他隐约听到女孩们的尖叫声，大声喊着有人袭击了她们。斯坦贝克博士问尼尔斯他当时看到了什么。尼尔斯说帐篷顶落在他们身上。一个男人开始用尖锐的武器（也许是一把刀）以及像铁管一样的坚硬武器击打他们。斯坦贝克博士问尼尔斯是否以前见过这个男人。
Nils didn't know. Then he described seeing blood all over Irmely's head. Look closely, do you see the man now? asked Dr. Stenbeck. Nils replied that yes, he could see. He described a man who was about 30 years old with long, fair hair. His face was round and pimply. The man was of average height and size, but looked strong, as though his work involved heavy labor. He wore a thick, dark plaid sweater, with green and black present in the pattern. A sketch of the man Nils described was widely circulated, and by the second month of the investigation, nine men had been arrested on suspicion of being the perpetrator. Each was subjected to intense interrogations, but all had solid alibis and were ruled out,
尼尔斯不知道。接着他描述看到英梅莉的头上全是血。“仔细看，你现在能看到那个人吗？”斯坦贝克医生问道。尼尔斯回答说是的，他能看到。他描述了一个大约30岁、留着金色长发的男子。那人的脸圆圆的，长满粉刺。这个男人身高和体型中等，但看起来很强壮，就像从事重体力劳动的人。他穿着一件厚厚的深色格子毛衣，图案中有绿色和黑色。尼尔斯描述的男子素描被广泛传阅，到调查的第二个月，已有九名男子因涉嫌行凶而被捕。每个人都经受了严厉的审讯，但所有人都拥有坚实的不在场证明，并被排除嫌疑，
as were friends, family, and acquaintances of the victims. The summer of 1960 soon turned to autumn, and the newspapers were no longer filled with near-daily articles on the Lake Buddha murders. Eventually, snow replaced the fallen leaves, and as the air turned cold, so did the case. Years then decades passed with no new viable leads. Police continued combing through tip-offs from the public, yet they seemed to become more and more outlandish as time went on. It wasn't until 2003 that the case's new lead investigator decided to utilize advances in DNA technology in the hopes to uncover previously undetectable evidence. Sepo, Tuliki, and Irmely's
受害者的朋友、家人和熟人也是如此。1960年的夏天很快变成了秋天，报纸上不再充斥着几乎每天都有的关于博登湖谋杀案的文章。最终，雪取代了落叶，随着空气变冷，这个案件也随之变冷。随后，几年乃至几十年过去了，没有出现任何新的可行线索。警方继续梳理公众提供的举报，但随着时间的推移，这些举报似乎越来越离奇。直到2003年，该案的新首席调查员才决定利用DNA技术的进展，希望能发现以前无法检测到的证据。塞博、图利基和英梅莉的
remains were exhumed for additional forensic examination, though failed to reveal anything of significance. However, the preliminary DNA testing of several key items from the crime scene, including the tent, did yield new information. It was enough for investigators to narrow in on a suspect. Finally, almost 44 years after the murders, police released a statement that a person of interest in the Lake Buddha murders had been detained. By this point, the suspect was a semi-retired bus driver aged in his early 60s, but in 1960 he was an 18-year-old who lived in the metropolitan area. Police interviewed him nearly a dozen times throughout March 2004, before arresting him on the 29th. To the shock of many, the man they had arrested was soul survivor,
遗骸被掘出进行额外的法医检查，但未能揭示任何有意义的东西。然而，对犯罪现场几个关键物品（包括帐篷）的初步DNA测试确实产生了新的信息。这足以让调查人员缩小嫌疑人范围。最终，在谋杀案发生近44年后，警方发表声明称，博登湖谋杀案的一名涉案人员已被拘留。此时，嫌疑人是一名60出头的半退休公交车司机，但在1960年，他是一名居住在大都市地区的18岁少年。在2004年3月29日逮捕他之前，警方在整个3月对进行了近十次讯问。令许多人震惊的是，他们逮捕的人竟然是唯一的幸存者，
Nils Gustafson. The police alleged that Nils had been intoxicated on the night of the murders. He had packed a condom for the trip, and investigators believed he had intended to use it until Irmely rejected his advances. Sepo was then forced to step up in order to protect the girls from an angry Nils. Their argument escalated, culminating in Nils being banished from the tent. Fueled by alcohol, resentment, and adrenaline, Nils then waited for his three friends to fall asleep before cutting the tent's guidelines to trap them inside. Then, knowing Sepo's position inside the tent, Nils began to attack him with a rock. Sepo defended himself by kicking Nils in the chin, causing his jaw to break. Further enraged by this injury, Nils took out his knife
尼尔斯·古斯塔夫森。警方指控尼尔斯在谋杀案当晚喝醉了酒。他为这次旅行打包了一个避孕套，调查人员认为他本打算使用它，直到英梅莉拒绝了他的求爱。为了保护女孩们免受愤怒的尼尔斯的伤害，塞博随后被迫挺身而出。他们的争吵升级了，最终导致尼尔斯被赶出帐篷。在酒精、怨恨和肾上腺素的驱使下，尼尔斯等他的三个朋友睡着后，割断了帐篷的牵引绳，将他们困在里面。然后，在知道塞博在帐篷内的位置后，尼尔斯开始用石头袭击他。塞博踢了尼尔斯的下巴进行自卫，导致他的下巴骨折。被这一伤势进一步激怒，尼尔斯掏出他的刀
and stabbed Sepo in the chest and neck. By this time, the girls had woken in a panic. As Tuliki tried to escape the confines of the fallen tent, Nils beat her in the head with the rock until she was no longer moving. Then he focused his attention on the true object of his rage, his girlfriend Irmely. Before Irmely could escape the tent, Nils smashed the rock down on her head, then stabbed her 15 times in the neck and shoulders. At some point during the attack, Nils sustained a deep gash to his arm and the side of his face. With each of his friends now dead, Nils got to work. First, he gathered up all the wallets and IDs and other items of some value, such as the keys to the motorcycles and Sepo's leather jacket and shoes. Then he disposed of
刺中了塞博的胸部和颈部。此时，女孩们惊慌失措地醒来。当图利基试图逃离倒塌帐篷的狭小空间时，尼尔斯用石头砸她的头部，直到她不再动弹。然后他将注意力集中在他愤怒的真正对象——他的女友英梅莉身上。在英梅莉逃出帐篷之前，尼尔斯用石头猛砸她的头部，然后刺了她的脖子和肩膀15刀。在袭击过程中的某个时刻，尼尔斯的胳膊和脸侧受了深伤。随着他的每个朋友现在都死了，尼尔斯开始动手了。首先，他收集了所有的钱包、身份证和其它一些有价值的物品，例如摩托车的钥匙以及塞博的皮夹克和鞋子。然后他处理掉了
them, either by digging a hole somewhere in the forest or throwing them into the lake, far from where the slaughter took place. Nils tossed Sepo's shoes into the forest scrub just off the road to the kiosk. He then carefully concealed his own blood-spattered shoes under a rock on the other side of the road. The man seen leaving the campsite early in the morning was, in fact, Nils. After disposing of everything, Nils returned to the campsite to continue his forensic countermeasures. He slashed the tent's canvas to give the impression of a more frenzied attack. Then, in either a final show of contempt or to fool the police into thinking the murders were sexually motivated, he stripped Irmily Naked from the waist down. He's staging of the crime scene complete,
它们，要么在森林里的某处挖个洞，要么把它们扔进远离屠杀发生地点的湖里。尼尔斯把塞博的鞋子扔进了小卖部路旁的森林灌木丛中。然后，他小心翼翼地把沾满血迹的自己的鞋子藏在路另一侧的一块石头下面。清晨被看到离开露营地的那个男人实际上就是尼尔斯。处理完所有事情后，尼尔斯回到露营地继续他的法医对策。他割破了帐篷帆布，给人一种更加狂热袭击的印象。然后，作为最后一次表示蔑视，或者为了愚弄警方认为谋杀是有性动机的，他剥光了英梅莉腰部以下的衣服。他布置的犯罪现场完成了，
Nils settled down on top of his murdered friends and waited to be discovered. The year Nils Gustafson was arrested for the Lake Budum murders, a 61-year-old woman named Tarja fronted a television crew to break an oath she had held since 1960. Tarja revealed that she had been at Lake Budum the night Nils and his group were present. 17 years old at the time, Tarja had been camping with friends at a public site on the shores of the lake when Nils and his group appeared. Nils was drunk and Tarja recalled a growing animosity between him and his companions. As to why she never told police of this case-hiding, Tarja claimed she had been sworn to secrecy by her group of friends.
尼尔斯在他被谋杀的朋友们身上安顿下来，等待被发现。尼尔斯·古斯塔夫森因博登湖谋杀案被捕的那一年，一个名叫塔尔娅的61岁女性面对电视摄制组，打破了她自1960年以来一直恪守的誓言。塔尔娅透露，尼尔斯和他的同伴在场的当晚她也在博登湖。当时17岁的塔尔娅和朋友们一起在湖岸的一个公共营地露营，当时尼尔斯和他的同伴出现了。尼尔斯喝醉了，塔尔娅回忆说，他与同伴之间的敌意越来越深。至于她为什么从未向警方讲述这起藏匿案件，塔尔娅声称她曾被自己的朋友圈子宣誓要保密。
While damning, Tarja's story didn't add up. She couldn't remember the names of the friends she was with that night other than one who was already deceased. The public campsite where she said Nils and the others had arrived didn't exist. She also claimed she was amongst the crowd when the injured Nils was stretched away from the collapsed tent, adding that there were no police officers present. However, one of the people who helped carry Nils was a police officer in full uniform. Tarja also couldn't describe anything about Nils, Seppo, Tuliki or Irmeli from 1960, including basic physical characteristics like their hair colour. Nils himself denied ever seeing Tarja that night and rejected claims that there was tension between his group during their
虽然很有罪证，但塔尔娅的故事却说不通。除了一个已经去世的朋友之外，她记不起那天晚上和她在一起的朋友的名字。她说尼尔斯和其他人到达的公共营地并不存在。她还声称，当受伤的尼尔斯被用担架抬离倒塌的帐篷时，她就在人群中，并补充说当时没有任何警察在场。然而，帮助抬尼尔斯的其中一个人是一名身穿全套制服的警察。塔尔娅也无法描述1960年尼尔斯、塞博、图利基或英梅莉的任何情况，包括头发颜色等基本身体特征。尼尔斯本人否认那天晚上见过塔尔娅，并反驳了关于他们的旅行期间他的团队之间存在紧张关系的说法。
trip. Tuliki's writings in her songbook supported his assertions. She had made no reference to an argument. Despite this, Tarja's recollections played a large part in the prosecution's case when 62-year-old Nils Gustafsson faced trial for the murders of Seppo boysman Tuliki Mackey and Irmeli Björklund in August 2005. As did a confession Nils had allegedly made while in custody awaiting trial. A police officer observed the seemingly frustrated Nils throw himself on the bed in his cell and exclaim, what's done is done, I'll get 15 years for it. Yet, there was no official record of this confession and Nils himself denied making the statement. He claimed that if he had ever said words to that effect, he would have just been
图利基在她的歌词本中的文字支持了他的说法。她没有提及任何争论。尽管如此，当62岁的尼尔斯·古斯塔夫森于2005年8月因谋杀塞博·博伊斯曼、图利基·马基和英梅莉·比约克隆德而面临审判时，塔尔娅的回忆在控方的案件中占据了很大一部分。尼尔斯在等待审判被关押期间据称做出的供词也是如此。一名警官观察到看似沮丧的尼尔斯将自己摔在牢房的床上，并大喊：“事已至此，为此我要被判15年。”然而，这份供词并没有官方记录，尼尔斯本人也否认发表过这种言论。他声称，如果他说过类似的话，那也只是在
venting about the situation he found himself in. The defences interpretation of the crime scene was vastly different to that of police. As Blood Spatter was only found on the exterior of Nils's shoes, investigators took this to assume he must have been wearing them when he went on his violent rampage. Yet, analysis showed that the blood on the shoes matched Spatter found at the tent's entrance, meaning they were by the door during the attack. Something else might have been blocking the insults, such as clothing or tent fabric. The defence pointed out that it was unlikely Nils had walked 500 metres barefoot or in his socks back to the tent after hiding his shoes. Both his feet and socks were clean.
宣泄他所陷入的处境。辩方对犯罪现场的解释与警方大相径庭。由于血迹仅在尼尔斯鞋子的外部被发现，调查人员据此推测他在进行暴力狂暴时一定穿著它们。然而，分析显示，鞋子上的血迹与帐篷入口处发现的血迹相符，这意味着它们在袭击发生时在门边。可能有其他东西挡住了入口，例如衣物或帐篷布料。辩方指出，尼尔斯藏好鞋子后，不太可能光着脚或穿着袜子走500米回到帐篷。他的脚和袜子都是干净的。
In a macabre display, the tent that the three victims had been slain in was displayed in the middle of the courtroom. Held up in place with string, the filthy yellowed canvas showed huge slash marks and was stained with blood. The prosecution stated that Nils had cut up the tent after the murders to embellish the attack. Yet, Blood Spatter once again suggested a different scenario. Analysis showed they were made beforehand. Furthermore, seven of Sepo's stub wounds were found to have been made through the tent. Only the blood belonging to the 14s was present on the tent, leading investigators to conclude that no other party was involved. However, only 20 samples taken from 11 locations had been tested. Therefore, it was not possible to conclusively determine
在一场毛骨悚然的展示中，三名受害者遇害的帐篷被摆在法庭中央。用绳子撑起的泛黄破旧帆布显示出巨大的割痕，并沾满了鲜血. 控方称，尼尔斯在谋杀后切开帐篷以夸大袭击。然而，血迹再次暗示了不同的情况。分析显示它们是事先造成的。此外，塞博的刺伤中有七处被发现是通过帐篷造成的。帐篷上只存在属于十四号的血迹，导致调查人员得出结论，没有其他方参与。然而，从11个地点采集的20个样本中只有部分进行了测试。因此，无法最终确定
that a fifth person's DNA was not present somewhere else. Additionally, many of the samples tested failed to yield any DNA information given the degradation of the evidence over 45 years. Tests did reveal that Nils Gustafsson's blood was present in the exact spot where he claimed to have been sleeping. During the trial, a disagreement arose between the testimony provided by neurology experts. Those speaking on behalf of the prosecution claimed Nils had suffered nothing more than a mild concussion, meaning he could have easily doctored the crime scene after the murders and that his claims of memory loss were unlikely. In contrast, experts for the defense stated that while Nils's injuries were not life-threatening, they were not minor either. He struggled with
第五人的DNA没有出现在其他地方。此外，鉴于证据在45年里不断降解，许多接受测试的样本未能产生任何DNA信息。测试确实表明，尼尔斯·古斯塔夫森的血液恰好出现在他声称睡觉的地方。在审判期间，神经学专家的证词之间出现了分歧。代表控方发言的人声称尼尔斯受到的不过是轻微脑震荡，这意味着他在谋杀后可以轻松篡改犯罪现场，并且他关于失忆的说法是不大可能的。相比之下，辩方专家表示，虽然尼尔斯的伤势并非危及生命，但也不算轻微。他在袭击发生后的几周里
balance in the weeks after the attack, during which time he was unable to walk unaided. They concluded that Nils unquestionably received significant head trauma capable of causing brain injury and memory loss. The trial of Nils Gustafsson for the murders of Sepur Boysman, Tulliki Maki and Irmeli Björklund concluded in October 2005. The panel of six district court judges retired to consider their verdict while Nils awaited his fate. Days later, Nils was sitting at home when he received a phone call from his lawyer. He had been acquitted. The lack of motive and the fact that witnesses had seen another unknown man leaving the crime scene
平衡感很差，在此期间他无法在无人协助的情况下行走。他们得出结论，尼尔斯毫无疑问遭受了严重的头部创伤，足以导致脑损伤和记忆丧失。尼尔斯·古斯塔夫森因谋杀塞博·博伊斯曼、图利基·马基和英梅莉·比约克隆德而受到的审判于2005年10月结束。六名地方法院法官合议庭退席审议他们的裁决，而尼尔斯则在等待他的命运。几天后，尼尔斯正坐在家里，突然接到律师打来的电话。他被无罪释放了。缺乏动机以及目击者看到另一个不明男子离开犯罪现场的事实，
convinced all of the judges that Nils was innocent. Moreover, the blood evidence confirmed that Nils was inside the tent when the attack occurred and his injuries would have prevented him from hiding the missing items. After the verdict was handed down, the prosecution had seen seven days in which to appeal. They declined to do so and on October 14, 2005 Nils Gustafsson's innocence was final. With the sole survivor of the attack at Lake Bulldom officially cleared, the crucial question still remained. Who was responsible for one of Finland's most notorious unsolved crimes? For many armchair detectives, there was still a question mark around one of the earliest suspects, Carl Gilstrom, dubbed the chaos man because he ran Lake Bulldom's chaos.
让所有的法官都确信尼尔斯是无辜的。此外，血液证据证实，袭击发生时尼尔斯在帐篷内，而他的伤势会使他无法藏匿失踪物品。宣判后，控方有七天上诉期。他们拒绝这样做，2005年10月14日，尼尔斯·古斯塔夫森的无罪判决最终确定。随着博登湖袭击案的唯一幸存者正式洗脱嫌疑，一个关键问题依然存在。谁是芬兰最臭名昭著的未破案件之一的幕后黑手？对于许多沙发侦探来说，最早的嫌疑人之一卡尔·吉尔斯特罗姆周围仍然有一个问号，他被称为混乱男，因为他经营着博登湖的混乱。
From the outset, Gilstrom's violent temper and attacks against people passing through the area had made him highly suspicious to many in the local community. Even though he didn't really resemble the police sketch of the suspect, one individual convinced of Gilstrom's guilt was Ulf Johansson. Ulf was 18 years old at the time of the murders and had visited the lake the very same day. As a young man who was around the same age as the victims and who always saw Lake Bulldom as a safe place to spend time with friends, Ulf had been horrified by the slayings. He'd also had his own run-in with Carl Gilstrom on the road leading by the man's house. Ulf was cycling along when Gilstrom threw rocks at him.
从一开始，吉尔斯特罗姆暴躁的脾气和对过往人群的袭击就让当地社区的很多人对高度怀疑他。尽管他长得并不太像警方的嫌疑人素描，但乌尔夫·约翰逊是一个坚信吉尔斯特罗姆有罪的人。乌尔夫在谋杀案发生时18岁，并在同一天参观了湖泊。作为一个和受害者差不多大、总是把博登湖视为和朋友一起度过安全时光的年轻人，乌尔夫对这些谋杀案感到震惊。他在那栋房子旁边的小路上也有过与卡尔·吉尔斯特罗姆的遭遇。乌尔夫正骑着自行车，吉尔斯特罗姆向他扔石头。
Ulf grew up to become a local politician and in 2016 he published a book about the case titled The Legend of Bulldom. In it, he collated many of the clues that pointed to Gilstrom, including his habit of cutting the guidelines of campers' tents. This idiosyncrasy was particularly troubling, given whoever had attacked the 14 ages used this exact method to catch his victims' unawares. Some time in the late 1960s, Gilstrom's wife was diagnosed with breast cancer. While in hospital, she made a startling admission to a friend. Her husband was the Lake Bulldom murderer. Although she had initially told police that he was at home asleep on the night in question,
乌尔夫长大后成为了一名当地政治家，并在2016年出版了一本关于该案的书，名为《博登湖传奇》。在书中，他整理了许多指向吉尔斯特罗姆的线索，包括他割露营者帐篷牵引绳的习惯。这种特质特别令人不安，鉴于任何袭击14岁年轻人的人都使用了这种确切的方法来让人防不胜防。大约在20世纪60年代末，吉尔斯特罗姆的妻子被诊断出患有乳腺癌。在医院期间，她向一个朋友做出了一个惊人的供认。她的丈夫就是博登湖谋杀案的凶手。尽管她最初告诉警方他在案发当晚在家睡觉，
now she claimed that she had only provided him with an alibi because she was scared Gilstrom would attack her and their children. After learning of this admission, police attempted to interview her again, but she refused to speak with them for fear of her husband. No physical evidence that Carl Gilstrom was the Bulldom Lake murderer was ever found, and the police closed their file on him in September 1969. According to Finland's Evening Newspaper, an 80-page police investigation file dedicated to Gilstrom came to light in 2005. Unfortunately, it shed no further light on his possible involvement. Suspicions have also remained around the other case suspect in the case,
现在她声称，她只是为他提供了一个不在场证明，因为她害怕吉尔斯特罗姆会攻击她和他们的孩子。得知这一供词后，警方试图再次讯问她，但她因害怕丈夫而拒绝与他们交谈。人们从未发现卡尔·吉尔斯特罗姆是博登湖谋杀案凶手的任何物证，警方于1969年9月关闭了对他的档案。据芬兰晚报报道，一本专门针对吉尔斯特罗姆的80页警察调查档案在2005年浮出水面。不幸的是，它没有对他的可能参与提供更多的光亮。关于案件中的另一个案件嫌疑人的怀疑也一直存在，
Hans Assmann, the German man who sought treatment at a Helsinki hospital the day after the murders. He'd raised suspicion amongst hospital staff due to his bizarre behavior, troubling comments, and resemblance to the police sketch. Following the release of the sketch, Hans Assmann suddenly shaved off his long pale hair, an act that could have been interpreted as an intentional effort to avoid comparisons. Jorma Palo, who had treated Assmann as a medical intern at the time, was so convinced of Assmann's guilt that he authored three books on the subject. He and Marty Paloaro, a former crime commissioner turned journalist,
汉斯·阿斯曼，这名德国男子在谋杀案发生第二天前往赫尔辛基的一家医院寻求治疗。由于他古怪的行为、令人不安的评论以及与警方素描的相似之处，他引起了医院员工的怀疑。素描发布后，汉斯·阿斯曼突然剃掉了他的金色长发，这一举动可以被解释为避免比较的刻意努力。当时作为医学实习生治疗过阿斯曼的约尔马·帕洛深信阿斯曼有罪，以至于他为此撰写了三本书。他和曾任犯罪专员后转为记者的马蒂·帕洛拉罗，
speculated that the police were refusing to investigate Assmann as a suspect due to sensitive national security matters. In 1997, an ailing Assmann granted an exclusive bedside interview to Marty Paloaro. During their conversation, Marty asked Assmann directly if he was responsible for the Lake Buldum murders. Assmann replied that he would, quote, not talk about the details. Marty took this as a confession. Hans Assmann died the following year at the age of 74. For many, suspicions that Assmann may have been the Buldum Lake killer were put to rest in 2005, when police unsealed an investigation file that related to him.
推测警方由于敏感的国家安全问题而拒绝将阿斯曼作为嫌疑人进行调查。1997年，病重的阿斯曼接受了马蒂·帕洛拉罗的独家床边采访。在他们的谈话中，马蒂直接问阿斯曼他是否应对博登湖谋杀案负责。阿斯曼回答说他，引述，“不谈细节”。马蒂认为这是自白。汉斯·阿斯曼于次年去世，享年74岁。对许多人来说，阿斯曼可能是博登湖杀手的怀疑在2005年画上了句号，当时警方解封了一份与他有关的调查档案。
Mika Mercer, a special reporter for Finland's Ilta Sanomat newspaper, was given access to the entire file, and on October 1, 2005, published an article on the findings. The file showed that in June 1960, after receiving the tip-off by the Helsinki Hospital doctors, the police had in fact investigated Assmann as a potential suspect. However, he was quickly ruled out on the basis of an airtight alibi. On the night of June 4, 1960, Assmann had shared a bed with his girlfriend in the same apartment as her sister and her sister's husband. According to witness statements by all three, Assmann arrived at about 6pm on June 4, and woke up on the morning of the Lake Buldum murders at 9.
芬兰《晚报》特约记者米卡·默瑟得以查阅全部档案，并于2005年10月1日は发表了一篇关于调查结果的文章。档案显示，1960年6月，在接到赫尔辛基医院医生的举报后，警方实际上已将阿斯曼作为潜在嫌疑人进行了调查。然而，由于拥有坚不可摧的不在场证明，他很快被排除在外。1960年6月4日晚，阿斯曼与女友在她的姐姐和姐夫所在的同一间公寓里同床共枕。根据三个人的证词，阿斯曼于6月4日下午6点左右到达，并在博登湖谋杀案当天的早上9点醒来。
Police also interviewed several witnesses who confirmed that Assmann had been painting at a construction site on both Saturday June 4 and Sunday June 5. On Monday, the construction site's caretaker gave Assmann a bottle of wine and the two men indulged. According to Assmann's wife and his regular doctor, he had been suffering from severe stomach pains for some time. After drinking the wine, these pains returned, and Assmann called his wife to collect him. When she arrived, she found him unconscious and called the paramedics. An ambulance delivered them to Helsinki's surgical hospital, where Assmann was treated. According to the police file, the stains that were on his clothes that day were paint, not blood.
警方还走访了几位证人，他们证实阿斯曼在6月4日星期六和6月5日星期日都在一个建筑工地画画。周一，建筑工地的看守给了阿斯曼一瓶酒，两人尽情痛饮。据阿斯曼的妻子和他的常规医生说，他一段时间以来一直遭受着严重的胃痛。喝了酒后，这些疼痛又复发了，阿斯曼打电话叫妻子来接他。当她到达时，发现他已经失去了知觉并叫了救护车。救护车把他们送到赫尔辛基的外科医院，阿斯曼在那里接受了治疗。根据警方档案，那天他衣服上的污渍是油漆，而不是血迹。
In 1978, police checked the foreign fingerprint on a soda bottle found at the Lake Buldum crime scene. It did not match Assmann's. Despite the release of Assmann's police file, many true crime enthusiasts remain convinced that he could have been the Lake Buldum killer. One reason for this is his likeness to the police sketch that was produced following Nils's hypnosis session. There are only a few photographs of Assmann in circulation today, one of which bears a striking resemblance to the composite. There is another photograph widely available on the internet that was supposedly snapped at the funeral of Sapo Boiseman, Tulliki Mackie and Irmely Björklund on June 13, 1960.
1978年，警方检查了在博登湖谋杀案现场发现的一个苏打水瓶上的外国指纹。它与阿斯曼的不匹配。尽管阿斯曼的警察档案被公之于众，但许多真实犯罪爱好者仍然确信他可能是博登湖杀手。原因之一是他与在尼尔斯催眠疗程后制作的警方素描相似。今天流传的阿斯曼照片只有少数几张，其中一张与合成图惊人地相似。互联网上广泛流传着另一张照片，据说是摄于1960年6月13日塞博·博伊斯曼、图利基·马基和英梅莉·比约克隆德的葬礼上。
The photograph depicts a large group of mourners. Standing towards the centre is a taller man. Unlike most of the other attendees, he is not looking straight ahead or casting his gaze downward in a solemn expression. Instead, his somewhat bulbous eyes seem fixated on something to his left. His face is angular, with protruding cheeks, a straight nose and a strong jaw. He looks strikingly similar to the suspect sketch. Some believe that this man is also Hans Assmann. This speculation relies heavily on the accuracy of the description given by Nils Gustafsson while under hypnosis. In the decades since 1960, the use of forensic hypnosis has proven to be unreliable. Studies have shown that hypnotised subjects may be more vulnerable to recovering
照片描绘了一大群哀悼者。站在中心附近的是一个个子更高的男人。与大多数其他与会者不同，他没有直视前方或面带庄严的表情向下看。相反，他有些突出的眼睛似乎盯着他左边的一样东西。他的脸部有棱有角，颧骨突出，鼻子笔直，下巴坚毅。他看起来与嫌疑人素描惊人地相似。有些人认为这个人也是汉斯·阿斯曼。这种猜测在很大程度上依赖于尼尔斯·古斯塔夫森在催眠状态下给出的描述的准确性。自1960年以来的几十年里，法医催眠的使用已被证明是不可靠的。研究表明，被催眠的受试者可能更容易恢复
false memories or being overly confident in their recollections, even when such memories are false. The Sixth District Court judges at Nils's trial did not consider his recovered memories to be reliable in any way. Nils himself has said that he has no recollection of what he said while hypnotised. Consequently, the descriptions he provided of the suspect at that time cannot be verified. As of late 2021, 61 years have passed since the brutal murders of Seppo Boysman, Tulikimaki and Irmeli Björklund. All three were laid to rest side by side in the Helsinki Parish Church Cemetery. In the decades since the tragedy that claimed the lives of his girlfriend and best friend, Nils Gustafsson has never had any criminal record, nor has he exhibited any signs of being
虚假的记忆，或者对他们的回忆过于自信，即使这些记忆是假的。尼尔斯受审时第六地方法院的法官认为他的恢复记忆在任何方面都不可靠。尼尔斯本人曾表示，他不记得自己在被催眠时说过什么。因此，他当时对嫌疑人的描述无法得到证实。截至2021年底，距离塞博·博伊斯曼、图利基·马基和英梅莉·比约克隆德被残酷谋杀已经过去了61年。这三人并排安葬在赫尔辛基教区教堂墓地。在夺走他女友和最好朋友生命的悲剧发生后的几十年里，尼尔斯·古斯塔夫森从未有过任何犯罪记录，也没有表现出任何迹象表明他是
an angry or violent man. Many believe that the murder charges brought against Nils were a fumble in the dark from a police force burdened by one of Finland's most infamous unsolved crimes. Nils described how, after his arrest, the police seized his family photo albums. Some of the private personal pictures within were splashed across newspapers the following day. During the trial, salacious headlines focused on the prosecution's baseless claims of drunkenness, sexual jealousy and rage. Hounded by the media, Nils and his family were forced to hide in their home. After his acquittal, Nils was found to have suffered deprivation of liberty and loss of reputation. He was awarded compensation in the form of 45,000 euros.
一个愤怒或暴力的人。许多人认为，对尼尔斯提出的谋杀指控是 burdened by 芬兰最臭名昭著的未破案件之一的警察部队在黑暗中的一次失误。尼尔斯描述说，在他被捕后，警察没收了他的家庭相册。其中的一些私人私密照片第二天就被泼洒在报纸上。在审判期间，耸人听闻的头条新闻集中在控方关于酗酒、性嫉妒和愤怒的毫无根据的指控上。遭到媒体的纠缠，尼尔斯和他的家人被迫躲在家中。在他被宣告无罪后，尼尔斯被发现遭受了人身自由剥夺和声誉损失。他获得了45,000欧元的赔偿。
Decades later, advances in forensic technology tried and failed to shed light on the murders. So much time has now passed that many believe the identity of the killer will likely remain an enduring mystery. Nine years after the murders, the kiosk man, Carl Gilstrom, was drinking with a when he suddenly grew extremely angry. Then, just as quickly, his mood switched to one of despair. Beria couldn't figure out what was wrong. Gilstrom blurted out, don't you realize, I'm Bulldom's murderer, what am I going to do? Beria apparently frightened by this outburst told his neighbour, if you are the murderer of Bulldom, then go and drown yourself and do it right away,
几十年后，法医技术的进步试图揭示谋杀案真相，但都失败了。现在时间已经过去了这么久，以至于许多人相信凶手的身份可能会永远成为一个谜。谋杀案发生九年后，小卖部男卡尔·吉尔斯特罗姆正在和一个喝一杯，突然变得异常愤怒。然后，就像这样快，他的心情转为绝望。贝里无法弄清出了什么问题。吉尔斯特罗姆脱口而出：“难道你没意识到，我是博登湖的凶手，我该怎么办？”贝里显然被这种爆发吓坏了，对他的邻居说：“如果你是博登湖的凶手，那就去淹死自己，马上去做，
because otherwise they will put you in a small prison cell for the rest of your life. At about six that same evening, Gilstrom's 15-year-old son couldn't find his father. He went out looking for him around the lake and eventually came across some people who told him that they'd seen his father swimming just off the eastern peninsula on the south shore. It was a location where he often swam, right near where the Lake Bulldom murders occurred. But Gilstrom's son saw no sign of his father in the lake. When Gilstrom failed to reappear, police were summoned to Lake Bulldom to undertake a search. A short while later, Gilstrom's body was found floating just off the headland. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
因为否则他们会把你关在一个小牢房里度过你的余生。”那天傍晚六点左右，吉尔斯特罗姆15岁的儿子找不到父亲。他出去在湖周围找他，最终遇到了一些人，他们告诉他，他们看到他的父亲在南岸东半岛附近游泳。那是他经常游泳的一个地方，就在博登湖谋杀案发生的地方附近。但吉尔斯特罗姆的儿子在湖里没有看到父亲的踪影。当吉尔斯特罗姆没有重新出现时，警察被召集到博登湖进行搜查。不久之后，人们发现吉尔斯特罗姆的尸体漂浮在岬角附近。目前还没有针对这一集的评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子以发表评论。